>> HE WENT THROUGH A SYSTEM
AND WE GOT HIM OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
HIM OUT FOR A LONG TIME.
[[INAUDIBLE]]
>> THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH ANYTHING.
THERE WAS NO DEAL MADE AT
ALL.
THERE WAS NO DEAL.
BUT, WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE HIM AND HAVE HIM IN
GOOD SHAPE.
I HEAR HE IS IN VERY GOOD
SHAPE.
>> Sean: THAT WAS PRESIDENT
TRUMP EARLIER TONIGHT
TALKING ABOUT THE RELEASE OF
AMERICAN PASTOR ANDREW
BRUNSON.
JOINING US NOW ON THE PHONE
FROM THE AMERICAN CENTER FOR
LAW AND JUSTICE, ALSO THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY AND
ALSO AT TIMES HE HAS BEEN
MINE.
JAY SEKULOW YOU HAVE WORKED
ON THIS CASE, JAY, FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING, I KNOW HOW
HARD YOU WORK.
I KNOW HOW HARD THE
PRESIDENT HAS WORKED ON
THIS.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS TONIGHT.
>> NO, THIS IS A BIG WIN.
WHEN YOU DID THE
INTRODUCTION I FEEL LIKE I'M
REPRESENTING EVERYBODY
TONIGHT.
WHAT A GREAT DAY IT IS FOR
THE BRUNSON FAMILY AND FOR
PASTOR BRUNSON HIMSELF AND
THE PRESIDENT AND
ADMINISTRATION DID A
FEBRUARY NOMINAL JOB MOVING
THIS CASE FORWARD.
I HAVE HANDLED A LOT OF
THESE.
THE FACT IS THEY ARE
DIFFICULT.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THERE
IS PROGRESS AND THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN THEY ARE NOT.
THIS WAS EVEN MORE
COMPLICATED BECAUSE IT WAS A
NATO ALLY.
THE END RU89 OF IT POSITIVE
ASPECT OF THIS, IS THAT THE
PASTOR HAS BEEN RELEASED
UNCONDITIONALLY AND IS
ENROUTE MAY HAVE ALREADY
LANDED IN GERMANY AND COME
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES AS
EARLY AS TOMORROW.
GREAT WIN AND HUGE THANK YOU
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE PRESIDENT AND TO MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS AS WELLING.
THE PRESIDENT REALLY LED THE
CHARGE HERE TO GET THIS DONE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> Sean: THERE WAS NO DEAL.
AND THE CHARGE FOR PASTOR
BRUNSON WAS HE WAS PREACHING
THE GOSPEL, RIGHT?
>> YES.
I MEAN, ACTUALLY THE
INDICTMENT ITSELF HAS THE
WORD IN TURKISH, OF COURSE,
IT'S CALLED
CHRISTIANIZATION.
THAT IS THEY VIEW THAT ACT
OF RUNNING A SMALL CHURCH,
SHARING THE GOSPEL AS AN ACT
THAT WAS AN ACT OF
TERRORISM.
THAT'S HOW THEY DEFINE IT
THIS WAS A TERRORISM CASE,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
BUT, AGAIN, THE GREAT NEWS
IS HE HAS BEEN RELEASED.
HE HAS BEEN RETURNED.
I APPRECIATE YOU COVERING IT
AND, AGAIN, APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT THE PRESIDENT
DID IN GETTING THIS
ACCOMPLISHED FOR THE FAMILY.